farming in Gaza was already an uncertain
way to make a living the Israeli
blockade restricts access to modern
technologies and materials and to wider
markets the coronavirus has made a bad
situation much worse people in Gaza have
lost their jobs and the coronavirus has
completely crippled economic activity
restaurants and kitchens
are shutdown wedding parties used to
order lots of chicken and are now
cancelled almost all our orders have
been canceled Hamas Iran administration
has begun some measures to keep the
agriculture sector operating having
banned agricultural exports entirely to
ensure supply for Gaza it's giving
livestock farmers a million dollars
worth of vouchers for animal feed while
the whole world is suffering because of
coronavirus shutdowns we are trying to
enhance resilience of this sector and
keep it working at maximum capacity to
guarantee the food security for people
in Gaza but farmers say it doesn't make
up for their losses
Garza's isolation thanks to the 14 year
long Israeli an Egyptian siege may have
helped keep coronavirus largely out but
it's also damaged the economy
unemployment last year was at 45% more
than half the population lives in
poverty
the additional damage done by the
closure of shops and restaurants means
prices have tumbled since the breakout
of coronavirus the commercial traffic is
so weak because people are afraid its
added to the economic difficulties of
Gaza citizens people now prefer to save
their money than their pockets from next
week the Agriculture Ministry is
promising to extend support for
vegetable farmers hit by a sudden drop
in demand just weeks ago a one-kilo bag
of onions would cost 55 cents now it's
half that the situation remains as it is
I'll stop and stay at home because I
can't continue being from a pocket and I
will not have enough to feed my children
liberty even if the virus itself is
being kept at bay in Gaza the fear of
its long-term economic effects is
spreading Harry Fawcett al-jazeera